we are Friday night here in LA we're
alive it's about 7:15 on the west coast
Paris is 12 hours ahead I think so we
don't have every bit of information the
last body count I heard was over 150
when when the Charlie Edie beau thing
happened in the week after everybody
said just sweet charlie but not really
they didn't really stick with them like
us her and I were just talking about um
I asked Tara if things would be
different I'm going to ask you this
question that people asked after 9/11
because I don't think we still know the
answer why do they hate us I've stumped
the panel yeah because we finance the
the capital flow into Saudi Arabia that
then arms the population that has power
in Saudi Arabia to oppress the
population that does not have power in
Saudi Arabia which then is deprived of
basic resources in Saudi Arabia which is
then radicalized inside the Muslim
religion and then lashes out
irrationally violently murderously
against innocent people who did nothing
the United States lack of a look at we
need to be accountable in our own
government it's our own relations
without a Arabia that's not what
terrorists say well when when when you
captured one heiress or when they leave
a note you know what they say cuz you're
there because you're in Muslim lands I
have a crazy idea why don't we get out
of Muslim land
part of it I think I think the idea I
think the idea of importing democracy
that that concept that that sort of
emerged in the early 2000s certainly
part of the Bush Doctrine at the time to
talk about sort of taking our values and
transplanting them elsewhere has wholly
been rejected because now by the
Republican buy-in yeah and that's and
that's a lot of the struggle you see
within the party today is that that's
Fisher that's growing between big
government republicanism for example and
this idea that you know Rand Paul and
others are talking about we're you know
let's let's be a little bit more common
sense about how we project power it's
like when you watch Star Trek Kirk goes
to the other planet and he brings
democracy they don't want it they don't
care if we're violating ball over here
know what Kripke and then he always says
what is this Earth kiss we're financing
the oppressor bill we are financing the
oppressor you know I think you're seeing
that a little through America centric
eyes I mean that certainly is part of it
I don't know if that's the main thing on
their minds and is the financing aspect
of it yes I think that's that's not
nothing it doesn't exist without that
relation so there would be no is what
I'm saying is we politically the only
thing we can control is our relationship
and our accountability with our
government and our government chooses to
fund well and b-prime awesome and for a
number of people who like Americans but
don't like America we're guessing are
you going to go that's right oh we had
some where they were very nice I mean
they all think we're like Donald Trump
loud brash making demands we're going to
do this I'm going to kick ass well
that's existed if they watch the
Republican debate on Tuesday night
that's exactly what they saw the biggest
cheers were for Republicans who got up
there and said we have to kick ass
militarily this nonsensical argument you
mentioned it before and you know let's
show a little bit of the debate this is
the debate that Ron Paul ran Ron Paul he
actually good for anyway he went he
sounded a little like he was father and
that's what we loved about
at the beginning this is a debate with
Marco Rubio how is it conservative to
add a trillion dollars in military
expenditures you cannot be a
conservative if you're going to keep
promoting new programs that you're not
going to break I know that the world is
a safer and better place when America is
the strongest military power in the
world can you be a conservative and be
liberal on military spending can you be
for unlimited military spending and say
oh I'm going to make the country safe
though we need a safe country but you
know we spend more on our military than
the next 10 countries combined yes what
a great thing to say because these all
these other Republicans talk about
rebuilding the military it's already
built where if we're already ten times
what all the other countries combined
are why do we have to keep adding to it
that for me was probably a seminal
moment in this presidential race simply
because it really exposed the fissure
between the neocons who want to expand
defense spending and engage militarily
and and the pure economic rationale
thought about where do you get the money
from how do you pay for it we just went
through that we just spent trillions of
dollars that were unaccounted for
that caused a lot of problems in a lot
of pain are you willing to repeat that
and I think Rand Paul really prescient I
think you're going to see more pressing
of that over the next few months
going into the primary a season in
February because that's got to get
resolved and and you cannot go forward
with this idea that we're going to ramp
up all this spending I mean Markos plan
is a two trillion dollar plan a trillion
dollars in defense spending and a
trillion dollars in a government subsidy
program for it for child care it so rain
is asking so we're you going to get two
trillion dollars from your complaining
about the 19th trillion dollar debt that
we currently have and that's the rest of
my seminal moment in the debate you had
Ben Carson calling himself a failed
murderer and Trump calling him a liar
I try to kill I know you can never be
too macho you never be too macho will
never be too much with the Republican
Party then they always talk about you
know I'm going to wipe out Isis first of
all that's not possible you know that to
wipe out Isis this idiot talk we have to
stop if we actually put boots on the
ground
what would Isis do they would melt back
into the population just like the last
time we were in Iraq you can't wipe them
out you can't wipe out all your enemies
Michael clue agree I mean I think this
if I can this but that's that's that's
part of the problem that the President
Obama is facing right now in looking at
what he's going to do with with the
group of 50 you know folks that he's
sending into Syria again you've got the
problem with Isis the country has to
come to grips with how we want to engage
militarily in the Middle East and and
and recognize that we have partners I
mean look at the Kurds why aren't we
doing more with the partisans what I
think this is a place where I actually
believe Bernie Sanders has articulated
this the best issues
what about the rest of the world what
about the money in Saudi Arabia Saudi
Arabia what about the folks inter why
are the American taxpayers the only
government the only person supposed to
fund in salsa I solve the Middle East
have been squarely at odds where the
Chinese New Year Saudis the
well there are all the other Arab
countries who pretend to hate Isis so
much precisely I tallied up their armies
one night there are over 5 million
people under arms if you look at all
these countries Saudi Arabia and Jordan
and Turkey that could send troops to
fight an army of about 25,000
who have 1970 Troy Yoda pick up and what
they've typically done so there's a good
car very reliable what they've typically
done is that we they rely on the United
States just sort of fill out that card
for them and exactly and that has been
the role that we have taken going back a
long time now but this is a different
dynamic this is a different war this is
different level engagement as we see in
Paris tonight as we've seen in Boston
for example it's it's it's a homegrown
thing but bonding over there is what is
causing the Paris thing to happen that
connection needs to be made yes we don't
have to be bombing them there we don't
have that we don't have to be bombing
them right I have to be us remember
after 9/11 Bush was all about we're
gonna we're going to not make any
distinction between countries the harbor
terrorists and terrorist and it was
kick-ass yet everybody loved it because
we had to wipe out the safe havens right
that was Afghanistan ok all these years
after 9/11 just way more safe havens and
the Worthen that we built that we
created and who is our best ally in Iraq
right now Iran exactly
Isis is tomorrow our big enemy is
fighting our other big enemy we don't
need to we just need oh my corn just sit
back and watch
this is crazy
you